und jetzt geht es um einen mann der
richtig sauer war richtig richtig sauer
da gab es ein bisschen ärger bei der
bauabwicklung und er hat sich dieser
mann in bagger gesetzt und einfach
abgerissen er hat es einfach gemacht er
hat die balkone einfach abgerissen jetzt
genau dieser prozess in donaueschingen
mal wieder einen schlechten tag bei der
arbeit gehabt einfach mal dampf ablassen
kann man machen aber dann bitte nicht zu
diesem baggerfahrer brannten im juli
letzten jahres wohl die sicherungen
durch kurzerhand reist der
bauunternehmer einfach die frisch und
selbstgebauten balkone dieses
mehrfamilienhauses in blumberg baden
württemberg ein stellt sich nach seiner
tat direkt der polizei also vereinfacht
gesagt sind leer stehendes gebäude es
kam niemand zu schaden es war auch
absehbar dass niemand zu schaden kommt
ist es einfach mal eine sachbeschädigung
da gibt es auch einen speziellen
straftatbestand nach dem paragraf 315
strafgesetzbuch das nennt sich
zerstörung von bauwerken
da gibt es eine strafandrohung von der
geldstrafe ein bisschen zu einer
freiheitsstrafe jetzt geht der fall vor
gericht das urteil wird auch noch am
selben tag verkündet der angeklagte
begründet seine tat kurz nach dem
vorfall mit wut er sei auf den
generalunternehmer sauer gewesen da er
zu unrecht zahlungen vorenthalten haben
er habe aus purer verzweiflung
der investor aus berlin weist diesen
vorwurf damals schon zurück wir haben
war da immer wieder geld brauchte ihm
insgesamt 93 5 prozent seines werkes
schon bezahlt ist er
gewährleistungsarbeiten über 15 prozent
die gezahlt werden sollten wenn alles
fertig ist und er war ihm gestern nicht
fertig und hat auch keine rechnung
gestellt diese hände richteten einen
schaden in höhe von über 2,6 millionen
euro an dann werden wir versuchen wege
und mittel zu finden diese beträge
geltend zu machen angeblich hatte immer
wieder erklärt hat er große
vermögenswerte in kroatien aber das wird
man sehen und dann das urteil ein jahr
und fünf monate auf bewährung diese
aktion wird der bagger kommt noch lange
bereuen
[Musik]